et comme chaque mardi wilfried est riche
il nous rejoint pour parler politique
bonsoir wilfried alors pour lui dit ce
sera donc non ce sera donc bon soir
florane n'ont pas de participation à la
primaire de la droite et du centre
voulue par les républicains l'union des
démocrates et des indépendants tenait
son congrès dimanche au palais des
congrès justement à versailles dans les
yvelines les adhérents devaient se
prononcer sur une présence à cette
désignation du candidat à la
présidentielle se déroulera en novembre
prochain et à 67% ils ont refusé
le chef de file des centristes jean
christophe lagarde s'est réjouie de
cette décision et dans les couloirs
versailles et nous avons retrouvé des
élus yvelinois notamment arnaud richard
il est député responsable départemental
de l'ud dei
il rappelle lui tout de même que l'union
a jusqu'à maintenant fait la force
on les regarde et les cantonales on a eu
un accord avec les républicains on a
gagné le grand chelem aux divines et
nous n'aurions pas gagné quelques
cantons si nous avions été désunie
les républicains et nous les régionales
nous avons gagné avec valérie pécresse
dans l'union donc je crois qu'il faut
que chacun devienne pas un prénom bien
conscience que vu le niveau des scores
du front national ne pas être unis est
désormais impossible donc il faut
trouver les mois et moyens de l'union
simplement pour faire une coalition ce
que nous proposons il faut être deux
voilà donc on a tendu la main aux
républicains et maintenant on attend de
voir quelle est leur réaction autre
personnalité centriste la mer des
clayes-sous-bois véronique côté millard
qui est également conseiller régional
vice présidente de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a insisté l dimanche lors
de ce congrès sur l'importance de
clarifier les positions l'image de lui
dit je pense qu'on manque de visibilité
et qu'il faut donc qu'il faut en donner
parce que il ya la droite et à la gauche
les extrême droite et extrême gauche
mais aussi des personnes qui sont là
beaucoup plus au centre
il ya des gens qui sont à légèrement au
centre qui sont plus adroits d'autres
qui sont légèrement aussi à gauche et
qui fera semblait donc toutes ces
personnes pour proposer un projet qui
soit différent des alternances que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya
une attente des concitoyens dans ce
domaine donc l'idée ne participera pas à
la primaire mais cela ne signifie pas
forcément qu'elle n'a partie sera prêt
parti à la présidentielle à la
présidentielle ni aux législatives qui
suivront d'ailleurs si l'udps ayez ces
dernières années fait le choix de
l'union avec les républicains pour les
élections départementales régionales
elle veut maintenant s'émanciper en tout
cas les alliés d'hier pourraient devenir
les ennemis de demain mais tout cela se
dit encore sur le bout des lèvres vous
avez entendu arnaud richard tout à
l'heure ce qui sera déterminant c'est la
place que la formation de nicolas
sarkozy sera prête à laisser à ces
centristes vous l'a écoutée avec arnaud
richard bien sûr mais cette place aussi
et qui pourrait être accordé dans un
hypothétique gouvernement ensuite dans
les circonscriptions lors des
législatives
écoutez maintenant les militants est que
nous avons rencontrés à versailles nous
leur avons demandé et quelle place
devait occuper leurs partis dans les
prochains mois pour la présidentielle
alors une place
alors là c'est compliqué en question je
pense que lui dit doivent faire valoir
déjà ses idées c'est à dire expliqué
qu'elle et son projet humaniste européen
nous sommes aussi pour une société
libérale de responsabilité et donc ces
thèmes doivent être partie intégrante du
débat présidentiel
on sait que toute élection se joue au
centre il faut trouver maintenant le bon
timing pour y participer et ce bon
timing il va bien sûr dépendre de la
façon dont nos amis républicains dont
nos alliés républicains sont prêts à
discuter de certains sujets
d'organisation avec nous je pense qu'il
doit prendre une place prépondérante
pour se faire entendre et après je crois
qu'il faut que ce soit la décision de
tous les adhérents et qu'on suive la
décision de tous les adhérents du vote
d'aujourd'hui et éventuellement s'il ya
d'autres des négociations avec les
républicains
voir une deuxième
la deuxième une deuxième question aux
adhérents lui dit est capable
aujourd'hui avec des cadres et et avec
les membres qui vont bientôt encore
adhéré on aura vraiment une puissance
forte et j'espère que bientôt nous
guideront les peut-être les
présidentielles dans cinq ans pour
pourquoi pas parce que là maintenant on
n'est pas préparé mais on sera préparée
pour dans cinq ans à bientôt et on sera
nous les battons vu dit alors on l'a
entendu certains imaginent déjà 2022 et
une victoire de l'élu
mais déjà après ce congrès à versailles
quelle sera la prochaine étape la
prochaine étape ce sont des rencontres
entre les chefs de file des républicains
d'alain juppé à nicolas sarkozy tout se
souhaite se trouver un accord rapidement
pour que les adhérents reprennent
pourquoi pas une nouvelle fois la parole
et accepte cette fois ci de participer à
cette primaire mais cela pourrait être
compliqué lui dit art repose rappelons
le sur un équilibre installé instable il
ya d'un côté les adhérents directs du
parti de l'autre il y a ceux du nouveau
centre et enfin il ya ceux du parti
radical trois formations qui cohabitent
au sein d'une seule et qui vont devoir
se mettre d'accord avec une 4e les
républicains elle même divisée sur
plusieurs projets vous avez deux heures
pour me donner le résultat ça risque
tout de même d'être compliqué surtout
qu'il faut ajouter à cette équation le
modem qui veut jouer son rôle 2017 sera
compliqué à gérer et pas uniquement à
gauche uniquement à gauche pour tous les
partis merci wilfried